I know that that there are many roles
where you get to employ your natural
British accent yes but there are
American words that you say have are
difficult yeah
for you too or for probably any Brit to
say in that act to say in a British
accent yeah I mean like the one that is
I do I said it once in a film and he's
only know this because I was so aware of
how stupid I thought I sounded as I said
it but the word badass or badass is like
that guy's badass that's how you say
that would I would naturally pronounce a
SS as us AR se like that's just how we
say that would so badass has this very
posh side like nothing sounds less
badass than saying badass like bad arse
is what yeah I mean I'm a real badass
like in an Irish accent in my workday
kind of like our English we just fall
flat same as I can say you all but I
cannot say y'all like y'all just sounds
like an English person it's just like
swallowing very hard as iron yeah it
just it's too far back it's just like I
can't say it you guys have the one thing
I love in the UK in general is you hear
these expressions and you're like oh my
god that is such a great expression
yeah the Brits have and and they're so
colorful and wonder if there any that
you grew up with that are real there's
there's one there's one there is a real
one that is definitely not heard in
America and I apologize because kinda is
pretty gross as well but like there's a
phrase for sweating in England that is
way I say in England my one friend says
this but like sweating like a
glassblowers also is a phrase that like
if you like it's one of those things
that like instinctively I got you doing
a manatee like dude you have no idea how
grateful I am right now
this guy is not here like it is like
blower by the way it's a big it's a
popular drugs like the cross blow in
community but ya know it's one of those
things that like I've never heard before
and I have no real image off and then as
soon as you hear it you immediately know
what it means
yes like sweating like a glassblowers
[ __ ] is fantastic I thought they work
in a hot environment that's a saint
yeah and that's where the air comes in
I'm glad you know the Beatles and that
phrase what we've given America thank
you who's to say when conservative
writer